um you uh I was telling you the album
that um I really got hit to you on was
uh the album you drive last year
neighborhood Hove uh crazy body of work
um appreciate that bro you got a new
single out with two chains obviously you
just shot a new video with whiz
um so I know you're prepping the new
album
um but talk about neighborhood hope why
did you like why that title
um so you know when I said neighborhood
hole you know that's the impact I got on
my neighborhood you know the same how
big you know Hove is and what he mean of
course to the game also you know I I
Feel Like My Story related is you know
how it was hard for him to kind of get a
deal you know they wasn't really
respecting what he had going on and how
he built this team and group of people
and just went crazy with it I mean I see
a lot of that in myself so that's why I
went with that what was um for you like
uh are you would you are you still
independent like what is your label
situation so I'm with my dog now you
know I got um a project over at Monarch
um shout out to Monarch you know I mean
they you know taking care of me did you
find that it was like hard for you to
get a deal or get a deal that you like
were comfortable with signing because I
think like it you could if you have any
sort of buzz you could probably get some
sort of situation but the terms are
probably terrible right yeah that's yeah
you say you you said it the right way
like find a deal that fit me because you
know I did so much alone already so I
just wanted to make sure that whatever
situation come you know I mean they just
add on to what I had going on and it
makes sense as far as the business so
you were pretty much strictly
independent up until when
um I want to see yeah just just you know
like recently [ __ ] what are the I mean
after that neighborhood was done through
distribution just distro yeah just
distro wow everything's been you know
alone what was the uh hard like you know
I feel like there's
gifts and curses to being fully
independent yeah more of your money but
you got to also work a lot harder you
got to work a lot harder and you know um
you just gotta you gotta yeah without
that machine you gotta you gotta do a
whole lot more and I mean I'm used to it
now you know I've been doing it so long
so